[Musik]
jetzt noch
meine geschichte
wittenberg mz
leonard buchholzer alias fritz
eichenberger diente als junger mann fünf
jahre lang in der französischen
fremdenlegion hier in marseille begann
seine karriere als kavalier ist heute
ist der innerschweizer über 90 die zeit
in der region war für sein ganzes leben
bestimmen erinnerungen
[Musik]
guten tag
ein ehemaliger legionär hier habe ich
vor 70 jahren unterschrieben
gerade mal 19 jährige war ihr was er
hier eine komplett neue welt betrat
[Musik]
darin habe ich die papiere für meine
fünf jahre unterschrieben
er wurde der kavallerie zugeteilt zum
glück sagt er
die infanterie hätte er nicht
durchgestanden
lennart holz ergab sich wie viele seiner
kameraden ein neues geburtsdatum und
einen neuen namen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die haben ja in der region noch nicht
geklärt was die krise die jährige kunst
und die erhebliche grundwasser nicht
religion und werden als 27-jähriger
verlässt er frankreich um fast sechs
jahrzehnte später wieder zurückzukehren
anstatt in ein schweizer altersheim
einzuziehen
entschließt er sich für den umzug in ein
heim für ehemalige legionäre
schon passiert
[Musik]
53 jahre später hatte sich entschieden
bei der region anzuklopfen und zu sagen
er möchte hier pensionär werden
leonard wollte nicht in ein schweizer
altersheim zwar gut aufgehoben aber mit
menschen die er nicht kennt und mit
denen er nichts gemein hat
es ist grausam nichts gemeinsames zu
haben
[Musik]
leonhard zieht die gesellschaft
ehemaliger legionäre vor männer die
gleiche erinnerungen teilen einen
legionär lasse man nie im stich heißt es
in orion
hier herrsche ein familiärer geist man
kümmere sich umeinander
leonard buholzer kommt am 8 oktober 1919
zur welt seine mutter elisabeth s und
sein vater leonhard buholzer heiraten
vier monate zuvor
[Musik]
leonhard und seine jüngere schwester
hatten keine einfache kindheit in form
und platzierte die beiden kinder
aufgrund schwieriger
familienverhältnisse in waisenhäusern
oder zum arbeiten bei bauernfamilien
leonhard ist immer wieder ausgerissen
bis er bei einem bauern in der nähe von
breitenbach mit einem knecht in kontakt
kam
und der brachte ihn auf eine idee
[Musik]
für menowin japan frankreich und 1
milliarde sparen damit am anderen morgen
in kairo und tücher können jandaya
rositz mehreren die bank mit einem
arbeitslose und zu recht kein papier
welche flächen am ende ganze struktur
oder durchfall region und ich liebe und
leonard zögerte nicht lang und er
behalte seinen entscheid nicht das leben
in der kaserne fand er geradezu luxuriös
täglich ein viertel liter rotwein und
sogar bisher
aber bald überrollte ihn eine andere
realität nach der ausbildung in tunesien
wurde leonhardts regiment 1940 an die
front geschickt im einsatz gegen die
deutsche wehrmacht kavallerie gegen
fliegerbombe demente die legionäre
kämpften auf verlorenem posten
[Musik]
das scheint vielen frühgeborenen und
natürlich hätte er nach deutschland
geschafft
leonard kaum von seinen verletzungen
genesen wurde in deutschland als
zwangsarbeiter in der rüstungsindustrie
im flugzeugwerk focke wulf eingesetzt
himmelfahrtskommando bomben ausgaben die
nicht explodierten und fachbuch
sperrgebiet und sofort bestellen
er hält sich natürlich auch das gehört
jetzt schon so ein wechsel hatte den pkw
versteckt und dann mit musik und reden
es ist doch relativ rasch arica und
entwickelt und trägt
leonhardt wollte sich seinem schicksal
nicht ergeben immer wieder wagte er
gemeinsam mit anderen gefangenen die
flucht erfolglos trotzdem liess er sich
nicht entmutigen
[Musik]
ich fürchte besonders im gedenken an die
die uns verlassen haben wünsche ich
ihnen und mir aufrichtig dass wir alle
uns nächstes jahr wieder hier zu diesem
fest versammeln können
[Musik]
rund 60 männer leben hier in der maison
du legionär jeder ehemalige legionär der
in besitz des so genannten zertifikate
bonbon tweet also eine art
leumundszeugnis ist ist hier willkommen
[Musik]
jeder ehemalige legionär der ledig und
selbständig ist kann hier wohnen
es ist möglich dass jemand nicht auf das
zivile leben vorbereitet ist
dann kann er auch nur vorübergehend hier
unterkunft bekommen
nach verschiedenen misslungenen
fluchtversuchen wurde der
kriegsgefangene leonhard buchholzer
unter misslichsten bedingungen aus
deutschland nach wien graz und weiter
nach maribor transportiert
[Musik]
im damaligen jugoslawien mussten die
deutschen kriegsgefangenen infrastruktur
arbeiten verrichten brücken und
festungsbau schienen verlegen
leonhard hatte nur ein ziel weg zusammen
mit mitgefangenen bereitet er einmal
mehr die flucht vor
[Musik]
das ich hab mir den ball stärken
die kraft einen mokka
diesmal gelang die flucht zu siebt
schlugen sie sich bis zu einer
abgelegenen alphütte durch
[Musik]
und er sich versteckt
und da nicht an
[Musik]
denn und damit zwei ganzen schritt
gemacht
die jugoslawischen widerstandskämpfer
brachten den immer noch völlig
geschwächten buchholzer und seine
kameraden in ein lazarett endlich in
guten händen
es war eine ehe unter schrecklichen
bedingungen leonhard kämpfte mit den
partisanen seine frau arbeitete weiter
als krankenschwester im lazarett bis zum
fatalen deutschen angriff
[Musik]
die werbung braucht
bitter verwundert über 100
[Applaus]
berlin
leonard kämpfte bis zum kriegsende
weiter gegen die deutschen in den reihen
der tito partisanen lediglich für mehr
anfangen mich aufgaben und ich zweimal
im wiener dialekt und der küche
kapituliert
leonhard bad im französischen konsulat
um aufnahme und rückführung nach
frankreich nach fünf jahren in krieg und
gefangenschaft und nach einer allzu
kurzen er
er wurde nach la rochelle zum ins minus
dienst eingeteilt
[Musik]
ich gehöre dazu ich kann ihnen die küche
wie ein tiger die kralle hannover auf
biologisch meint büro und das gebiet ist
frei und wenn den franzosen bunten
programm
[Musik]
hier am bande für mich ganz lassen
b
irgendwer muss doch wie sicher
also wenn die tinte markiert wurden sind
50.000
[Musik]
27 km der haube stellt durch die luft
damit war das abenteuer fremdenlegion
endgültig beendet leonhard konnte
einigermaßen unbehelligt in die schweiz
zurückkehren
wie in solchen fällen üblich wurde auch
er vor dass die vision gericht gestellt
dass hin dank seiner virulenten
selbstverteidigung freisprach heute ist
ein besonderer tag
leonard buholzer feiert seinen
neunzigsten geburtstag feiert ihn in
kreise der menschen die ihm am nächsten
stehen die er sich als familie
ausgesucht hat im süden frankreichs
im heim der ehemaligen fremdenlegionäre
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und ja
dollar
[Musik]
und mir